[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité manque d'essence
et envolés des prix à la pompe et si
vous passiez à l'électrique dans la
somme une entreprise convertissez vieux
bus pour fonctionner à l'hydrogène
présentation à suivre de où est au TV la
chaîne de la Voix du Nord dans un
instant chômage partiel et plan de
sobriété les entreprises s'adaptent pour
réduire leur coût de fonctionnement
exemple avec Vosges télévision et Canal
32 dans les coulisses de deux
entreprises poussées à la modération à
l'heure de l'hiver
un saut à l'élastique à 91 ans c'est le
défi relevé par Yvette dans la Sarthe un
seau pour la bonne cause dans le cadre
de l'opération octobre rose et le
dépistage du cancer du sein sujet de LM
TV Sarthe dans ce journal et puis enfin
nous vous emmènerons sur le chemin de
halage dans cette édition un sentier au
cœur d'une falaise dans le Lot et des
images époustouflantes de nos
partenaires de la Dépêche du Midi
pénurie et prix élevé à la pompe les
galères s'accumulent pour les
automobilistes français la patience de
chacun est mise à rude épreuve accepter
celle des propriétaires de véhicules
électriques une situation qui pousse à
la réflexion de nombreux conducteurs à
ce propos connaissez-vous le concept du
rétrophyte la conversion d'un véhicule
thermique en véhiculé électrique alors
si la tendance se développe déjà pour
les voitures les transports en commun
s'y mettent eux aussi dans la Somme le
premier bus serait profité au monde
vient de prendre la route de l'hydrogène
à la place du diesel c'est un sujet de
Jérémie Houbron pour oui au TV la chaîne
de la Voix du Nord
prendre un quart tout à fait
conventionnelle à ceci près qu'à
l'arrière
à cet emplacement on retrouvait le
moteur thermique avec la boîte et la
transmission qui ramène sur le pont tous
ces éléments et les accessoires qui
étaient alimentés par le moteur et qui
servait au bon fonctionnement ont été
enlevés pour venir intégrer toute une
solution électrique 0 émission une
solution plus verte basée sur
l'hydrogène et la production
d'électricité voilà ce qui fait de ce
quart un véhicule rétrophité
c'est-à-dire transformer de A à Z
désormais fini les émissions de
particules fines et le bruit du moteur
ça reste un véhicule silencieux
propre vous voyez mais j'irai même
j'ai même peut-être rassurant parce que
je suis tombé souvent en panne avec des
véhicules thermiques il a fallu à cette
PME picarde quatre années de travail et
plus d'un million d'euros pour concevoir
le véhicule et en obtenir tous les
brevets l'alternative aux énergies
fossiles fait déjà son chemin et séduit
plusieurs villes de France et au-delà je
pense que c'est l'avenir nous avons des
projets à des nouvelles installations
qu'on va construire ici dans geste en
Center donc nous pensons sortir 10
véhicules rétrocités par mois dans
quelques semaines ce carré profité
première mondiale commandée par la
région Normandie sillonnerait les routes
entre Rouen et Évreux laissant sur le
bas-côté ses homologues d'un autre temps
voilà qu'il soit thermique où électrique
l'écart comme les bus ont besoin d'un
chauffeur pour être conduit une évidence
alors que de nombreux postes sont à
pourvoir un peu partout en France en
nouvelle-aquitaine par exemple il
manquerait entre 400 et 500 chauffeurs
pour satisfaire les besoins de transport
dans la région pour pallier ce problème
Pôle emploi et la région Aquitaine ont
lancé une opération séduction auprès de
demandeurs d'emploi reportage d'Alix
Fourcade pour TV7 la chaîne du groupe
sud-ouest
le secteur de Langon depuis 6 mois
christelle est en recherche d'emploi
j'ai vu les annonces sur sur le journal
tout ça comme quoi il cherchait beaucoup
de chauffeurs de bus tout ça donc du
coup ben je sauté sur l'occasion comme
elle ils sont une trentaine à avoir
participé ce lundi à la journée de test
organisée par la région
nouvelle-aquitaine et Pôle emploi pour
devenir chauffeur de bus avec chacun des
motivations différentes
penser
pour ma retraite c'est un truc qui me
plaît en plus cette journée est le fruit
d'un gros travail d'enquête en amont
pour Pôle emploi qui attache et
d'identifier les raisons du manque
d'attractivité de cette profession on a
décidé de renverser un petit peu le jeu
en
ciblant spécifiquement des publics
auxquels ne mettiez pouvait correspondre
à travers des avantages en transformant
ce que certains pourraient considérer
comme inconvénient en avantage par
exemple le temps partiel le dépose à
l'issue de ce test dit demandeurs
d'emploi se verront offrir une formation
pour devenir chauffeur de
une formation entièrement financée par
la Région qui a constaté une forte
décrue du nombre de chauffeurs depuis le
covid pendant un long moment ce qui fait
qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui étaient
finalement dans ces métiers là qu'on en
trouvait d'autre on a à peu près 4000
chauffeurs en nouvelle-aquitaine cassure
les transports scolaires notamment il en
faudrait 400 à 500 de plus pour qu'on
soit véritablement dans une situation
normale le salaire d'un chauffeur de bus
aussi entre 1400 et 1600 euros nets
des problèmes de recrutement qui
résonnent avec une situation économique
difficile du fait de la hausse
spectaculaire des coups de l'énergie
particulier et entreprises les factures
s'envolent exemple dans les Vosges
l'entreprise tissage de France a dû
mettre une partie de ses salariés au
chômage partiel pour réduire ses charges
une mesure frustrante quand le carnet de
commande est bien rempli Anthony sapé un
Didier pour vos télévisions
une entreprise rachetée en 2018 avec des
actionnaires solides la marque de
vêtements et chaussures fabriquées en
France 1083 le groupe Lemoine leader
européen dans la fabrication de produits
d'hygiène en coton ou encore le fond
d'investissement terrifices nous sommes
chez tissage de France à
rupt-sur-Moselle qui a récemment
embauché et formé une vingtaine de
personnes pour son atelier de confection
qui a débuté fin 2021 les clients sont
là les carnets de commandes sont pleins
bref tout irait pour le mieux s'il n'y
avait pas cette fameuse crise
énergétique mondiale alors pour alléger
ses factures de gaz et d'électricité la
direction a décidé de réduire
provisoirement son activité on est dans
une activité sur le tissage très
énergivore un petit peu moins sur la
confection mais par contre sur le
tissage c'est vraiment un vraiment un
souci pour faire face à tout ça
effectivement il fallait réagir donc on
a une période d'activité partielle qui a
duré un mois mais maintenant il va
falloir rattraper le retard et puis
satisfaire toutes les commandes de nos
clients puisque
notre carnet de commandes est
complètement plein après cela il faudra
redéfinir les prix des produits en
fonction de l'évolution du coût de
l'énergie sachant que si la facture ici
a doublé entre 2021 et 2022 elle
pourrait être encore multipliée par 5 ou
6 en 2023 d'où l'idée d'anticiper et sur
une courte période d'arrêter des
machines deux jours par semaine
frustrant tout de même pour une
entreprise qui venait de lancer son
atelier confection avec un
investissement de 700000 euros dans
l'outil de production et une stratégie à
long terme en attendant tissage de
France investit encore on parle de 6 à
700000 euros pour 8 nouveaux métiers à
tisser plus modernes et moins
énergivores ils sont attendus en 2023
l'idée est de parvenir au moins à
stabiliser le chiffre d'affaires annuel
de 4 millions et demi d'eau
voilà et dans ce contexte le
gouvernement invite toutes les
entreprises à réduire leur consommation
énergétique nombre d'entre elles ont
déjà adopté ou sont en passe de le faire
un plan de sobriété baisse du chauffage
dans les locaux extinction des lumières
ou des outils informatiques les
solutions sont nombreuses et souvent
efficaces dans le temps vous allez le
voir la preuve dans l'Aube sur l'un des
Sites de l'entreprise Bonduelle images
et réactions récoltées par la rédaction
de Canal 32 sur place
ne serait-ce que d'enlever les couverts
que les réduire l'épaisseur des
plastiques on a réduit de presque 450
tonnes l'an dernier les plastiques à
titre d'exemple depuis 2015 on a divisé
par deux la consommation en eau sur le
site et on cherche aujourd'hui
énormément de pistes pour réduire les
consommations en électricité on va
vraisemblablement passer d'une semaine
de cinq jours à 4 jours l'activité
aidant parce que l'activité est plus
faible dans cette période et avoir tout
ce qui est lumière énergie coupée sur
les machines
réduire sa consommation énergétique
c'est aussi s'engager dans la
préservation de l'environnement à
l'instar du développement des énergies
propres parmi elles l'éolienne est
incontestablement la plus connue mais
aussi la plus débattue en France si son
aspect extérieur est souvent critiqué
pour en les dire les paysages son
intérieur lui nous est encore secret
alors que se cache-t-il dans une
éolienne les révélations et explications
de la chaîne TVR près de Rennes sur
reportage à la question à quoi ressemble
l'intérieur du néolienne voici la
découverte de l'une d'elles sur le parc
éolien de Teillet au sud-est du
département la visite commence par le
passage dans un monde change puis la
prise d'une échelle exigu avant de se
retrouver à 100 mètres de hauteur dans
ce qu'on appelle la nacelle la partie
rectangulaire au dessus du mât à la base
des pales c'est ce qu'on appelle le
moyeu ou
donc il y a les trois pales derrière moi
il y a la multiplicatrice qui permet de
multiplier donc l'énergie donc c'est à
peu près un rapport de 100 on arrive à
1200 tours minutes la génératrice
et derrière vous le convertisseur donc
ton petit derrière donc la 680 volts qui
est multiplié donc après avec le
transformateur en 20000 tirages et sur
le réseau cette éolienne à 3 millions
d'euros appartient à la société
bordelaise Valorem qui entend bien en
implanter beaucoup d'autres dans le
département elle devrait bénéficier des
dernières annonces gouvernementales en
faveur de ce secteur un projet comme ce
celui qu'on a juste derrière nous il a
mis 17 ans à se construire ce qui est
beaucoup trop long nous on pense que
c'est ces projets là on peut en prenant
le temps de concerter avec la population
en prenant le temps de faire toutes les
études environnementales nécessaires on
pense que c'est des projets qui peuvent
sortir de terrain 4 ans vallorem possède
déjà les quatre éoliennes du site de
Teillet installé en 2019 elle travaille
à ériger la prochaine pour 2025
une des grandes villes de France face
aux enjeux du changement climatique
voilà la thématique du magazine Le Point
dans sa dernière édition spéciale
consacrée à la ville de Nice
l'abdomadaire revient notamment sur les
menaces auxquelles est exposée la
commune entre os du niveau de la mer
incendie et tremblement de terre pour y
faire face Christian Estrosi le maire de
Nice réclame un choc de décentralisation
son interview et celle de Nathalie Hilmi
l'une des expertes du GIEC sont à
retrouver dans l'édition locale du point
cette semaine
après deux ans à l'arrêt les forains ont
repris de l'activité depuis quelques
mois exemple emblématique de ce retour à
la normale la ville de l'île Rousse a
enfin retrouvé sa foi la plus ancienne
de Corse avec ses 193 éditions au
compteur parmi les nombreux artisans à
exposants enfants et parents ont pu eux
aussi retrouver le goût si particulier
de la fête foraine alors comment
l'ensemble de la filière a-t-il survécu
pendant la crise et surtout comment se
passe ce retour aux affaires éléments de
réponse au micro de Loïc Leprince et de
Cyprien rebattait pour via télépaser en
Corse
et encore grand 8 auto-tamponneuse ou
encore machine à pince temps
d'attraction qui avait disparu de notre
quotidien pendant la crise du covid
depuis mai forain et foraine ont pu
reprendre du métier mais pour ses
professionnels difficile d'oublier cette
période compliquée parce que
les assurances à payer parce qu'il n'est
pas d'accord comme engrais qu'on soit
arrêté le jugement des assurances
aussi mais là ça va on est content
depuis le mois de mai on a tout le monde
a bien travaillé sur 24 mois on a
travaillé à peu près 4 mois donc on a eu
assez dur et mais là on est on est bien
reparti et on espère que ça va durer et
on a gardé nos prix on fidélise nos
clients depuis plus de 50 ans qu'on est
là donc on garde nos prix faut pas que
ça faut pas que ils ont subissaient
conséquences non plus mais continent
donc c'est pas la même clientèle
ici ben je pense qu'il y en a pas
beaucoup de manège comme ça vous n'avez
pas de parc d'attraction donc bah les
jeunes ici ils se lâchent plus que sur
le continent on va dire deux années
blanche pour les forums mais aussi pour
les enfants alors à la sortie des cours
impossible pour les écoliers de ne pas
passer à la foire de l'île Rousse
je viens
[Musique]
ment
les sourires sont bien revenus sur les
visages des forains et des enfants et si
ces professionnels ont travaillé
d'arrache-pied pour la Foire de l'île
Rousse le repos ne sera que de courte
durée dès la semaine prochaine beaucoup
repartiront installé leur manège au
Salon du Chocolat à Bastia voilà et les
amateurs de sensations fortes salueront
sûrement le courage d'Yvette Yvette est
une femme de 91 ans qui a décidé de se
lancer dans le vide un saut à
l'élastique à 45 mètres de haut au
profit de l'opération octobre rose et de
la lutte contre le cancer du sein cette
dynamique non-agénaire n'a qu'un mot
d'ordre profitez jusqu'au bout et
croquer la vie à pleines dents Hélène
Galiana a tenté de la suivre cette
sportive pour la rédaction de LMTV ça
regardez
un saut à l'élastique ça se mérite et
avant de foncer dans le vide il faut
monter les 45 mètres de hauteur qu'il a
sépare du viaduc et ça ne fait même pas
peur à Yvette c'est le pas pressé
qu'elle monte la centaine de marches au
sommet l'adrénaline l'attend
c'est moi
[Musique]
l'artiste
d'un certain âge et qui nous a demandé
si elle pouvait sauter à l'élastique on
était surpris au début on lui a demandé
son âge et sans hésiter nous a dit 91
ans donc on a réfléchi avec elle nous a
bien expliqué que c'était une femme
sportive et puis on a pris le challenge
à faire sauter à l'élastique et donc ça
fait son
quatrième saut là aujourd'hui il est
venu s'entraîner pour la Octobre Rose
une détermination qui force l'admiration
je suis très très étonné très
je trouve ça extraordinaire tout ce
qu'elle fait elle m'épate elle est
extraordinaire ça va je j'avais un petit
peu d'envoi mais
ça ça va ça va être mon tour ça va
c'est le rêve le rêve on pense à rien
voler voler voler je voudrais un oiseau
comme dans la chanson je suis un oiseau
rendez-vous au saut en parachute oui
c'est le prochain objectif oui quand
je sais pas peut-être cette année je
voudrais cette année enfin vous partage
le secret qu'elle nous a confié pour ce
maintenir en forme et il va te marchent
chaque jour environ 10 km
du courage et de la bravoure encore dans
ce journal avec l'hommage rendu à
Limoges au dernier survivant du massacre
d'Oradour-sur-Glane Robert et brasse qui
a survécu à l'une des pires tragédies de
la Seconde Guerre mondiale ce passeur de
mémoire a reçu la médaille de la ville
et à inaugurer la plaque d'un futur
centre de loisirs qui portera son nom un
lieu intergénérationnel comme un symbole
pour celui qui a perdu sa mère et ses
sœurs durant le massacre nazi qui fit
643 victimes en juin 1944 écoutez Robert
et brasse et le maire de la ville
d'Oradour-sur-Glane au micro d'Alan
Druot de la rédaction de 7 à Limoges
que lorsque je paye assister à être
honoré par la Ville de Limoges c'est
quand même quelque chose d'important
c'est important parce que ça a été un
vrai patient de mémoire et c'est
quelqu'un qui a œuvré sans relâche pour
la réconciliation en particulier à
réconciliation avec l'Allemagne
40 ans ça se fête en jaune et en bleu
quand on s'appelle Ikea la célèbre
marque suédoise a célébré son
anniversaire d'une drôle de manière dans
l'un de ces magasins à Saint-Étienne a
défilé était organisé au milieu des
allées par un lycée local des Métiers de
la Mode un événement surprenant et
pédagogique pour ses futurs créateurs
qui ont du travailler avec les fameux
sacs aux couleurs de l'enseigne comme
vous le voyez sur ces images de TL7 la
télévision de la Loire réaction
recueillie par Chantal joassard regardez
au niveau de la créativité on a laissé
les élèves d'instin faire des choses
donc démonter les sacs récupérer des
sangles créer du volume ils ont été
quand même assez brillants dans ces
exercices là dans la vie créatif on a eu
très très peu de temps entre le moment
où le défiler et puis le moment où il a
fallu le faire et il a fallu beaucoup
réfléchir trouver des solutions il y
avait certaines choses qu'on pouvait pas
faire juste avec du plastique parce que
ça a pas la même tenue qu'un tissu c'est
vraiment parti en fait d'une petite
aventure au départ et de voir
aujourd'hui c'est 40 tenues c'est plus
que incroyable
voilà incroyable et atypique de la part
de ses lycéens en tout cas bravo à tout
à fait autre chose huit tramoules
palourdes ou encore coquilles
Saint-Jacques les Français c'est bien
connu raffolent des coquillages et parmi
les régions les plus consommatrices on
retrouve bien sûr la Bretagne c'est à
vanne justement que se tenait il y a
quelques jours le salon de la filière de
la conchiliculture 140 professionnels ce
sont donnés rendez-vous pour présenter
les innovations du secteur très impactés
par les phénomènes climatiques le point
avec Laurence lorray de TBO la chaîne du
groupe télégram en Bretagne
le mollusque comestible connaît toujours
autant de succès avec une forte activité
en matière de consommation l'été dernier
seul bémol la sécheresse qui n'a pas
épargné la production de coquillages
depuis le début de l'année on a
quasiment pas eu de pluie ce qui fait
qu'on a pas d'apport de sel minéraux en
mer et donc la photosynthèse avec le
soleil se fait moins bien ce qui fait
qu'à a grossissement et ça c'est
vraiment vu sur les moules cette année
si la qualité de l'eau reste son cheval
de bataille la conchiliculture souhaite
également relever le défi
environnemental dans son ensemble et
nombreux sont les innovations
technologiques comme celle-ci ces poches
ostréicoles en biomatériot testé sur
1000 parcs en France il y a plus de
plastique tout est à base enfer végétale
mais on les travaille de manière à ce
qu'elle est là la propriété d'un
matériau traditionnel autre innovation
cette fois-ci en matière de recyclage ce
collecteur pour huître fabriqué à
l'origine avec 3 plastique
sera désormais proposé en monomatière
dès 2023 on se doit en tant que
revendeur d'avoir quand même sur ces
questions environnementales des choix
des choix pertinents à proposer à
l'avenir au niveau de nos matières et
principalement ces matières plastiques
qui sont quand même des matières très
communément utilisées dans les métiers
de la conchiliculture la filière
s'engage pour la planète éveille à ce
que l'on puisse continuer à déguster ces
produits uniques et délicieux
voilà et des trésors gustatifs de la
Bretagne passons aux richesses
aveyronnaises sur une péniche c'est le
concept original d'Aveyron en scène pour
sa troisième édition des chefs
d'entreprise et des décideurs du
département étaient invités à partager
un repas gastronomique à bord d'une
péniche au cours d'une mini croisière
sur la Seine une occasion idéale pour
renforcer les liens économiques entre la
capitale Paris et l'Aveyron mais aussi
pour découvrir les produits locaux
regardez ce reportage appétissant de
Christophe
une péniche au pied de la Tour Eiffel
pour mettre en valeur les produits d'un
département c'est le projet original
d'Aveyron en scène sur le bateau 5 chefs
vont préparer un repas gastronomique
pour une soirée événement qui va
rassembler les aveyronnés de Paris et
d'ailleurs et dans les assiettes tous
les produits sont avéréonnés
sur du Vau d'Aveyron et du Ségala un peu
notre produit phare de l'Aveyron
et on va travailler les filets mignons
qu'on a fait rôtir et ça sera servi avec
une escalope de foie gras juste poêlée
fait par des aveyronnés passionnés dans
l'Aveyron pour les avions de Paris
des ateliers de dégustation mettent en
avant des produits locaux comme la table
de Solange qui regroupe en Aveyron des
éleveurs bouchés depuis 7 générations
[Musique]
qu'on peut voir derrière moi donc une
histoire familiale petite entreprise qui
est dans le village dans une zone rurale
et en fait on fournit de la prestation
en boucherie mais aussi bien dans les
produits locaux charcuterie fromage de
la comme vous pouvez le voir sur la
table
maisons en scène c'est bien plus qu'une
croisière gastronomique autour des
tables 400 décideurs et chefs
d'entreprise une occasion de favoriser
les liens historiques qui se sont créés
entre la capitale et l'Aveyron beaucoup
d'avéronnés ont créé de très très belles
entreprises à Paris ils ont véhiculé de
l'Aveyron à Paris les valeurs de
l'Aveyron qui sont la valeur travail la
valeur solidarité la valeur authenticité
et aujourd'hui il y a autant d'avéronnés
à installer à Paris que tu avais remis
en Aveyron aviron en scène devient ainsi
un rendez-vous important pour l'économie
aveyronnaise dans ce genre de réunion où
on se retrouve en travéronais il
s'échangent beaucoup de cartes de cartes
de visite beaucoup d'idées et si ce soir
là si aujourd'hui ce soir il ne se fera
pas nécessairement des affaires c'est le
début d'un long cheminement qui peut se
faire entraveronner et rester au pays
bien et des avey qui sont sur Paris
qu'en Aveyron bien sûr que c'est
important de venir ici et après pour
pouvoir développer le jeunesse et les
vendre sur la capitale
après deux heures de croisière sur la
scène les avait René ont déjà pris date
pour la quatrième édition et continuer
ainsi à faire vivre cette belle histoire
entre Paris et l'Aveyron
ils sont davantage connus pour faire de
belles images de nos territoires ou pour
être exploités dans des missions de
surveillance les drones sont aussi
utilisés aujourd'hui dans les pandages
cette nouvelle méthode de dispersion
pourrait être une solution d'avenir pour
les vignerons notamment principal
avantages son usage simple dans des
zones difficiles d'accès et si la
réglementation est encore assez lourde
pour ces engins télécommandés la méthode
pour éviter de se démocratiser vous
allez le voir précision de Sébastien
Germain pour huit Mont-Blanc
Benoit pas un génie vignerons ni
viticulteur et pourtant on le retrouve
ce matin-là en train de traiter des
vignes du côté de Détrier en Savoie
cette opérateur de drone installé à
Juvigny en Haute-Savoie est en mission
depuis quelques temps il tente
d'importer en France les pandages par
drone une pratique très utilisée en
Suisse j'ai commencé en forêt donc
l'objectif c'était de développer
l'application drone en forêt et je
discutais avec mes collègues qui étaient
dans la viticulture champ de
l'agriculture et ils m'ont dit il y a un
réel besoin
d'apporter une solution dans les fortes
pentes alors certes même si la demande
est très présente l'utilisation de ce
drone atypique n'est pas sans contrainte
administrative notamment une étude de
risque rsol d'un poids minimum de 42 kg
l'appareil doit être immatriculé comme
un avion mais une fois ces difficultés
contournées son utilisation peut
s'avérer très opportune le gros avantage
du drone c'est la pénibilité du travail
c'est à dire que là encore c'est encore
mécanisable en chenillard mais il y a
des zones qui sont totalement manuelles
où là le drone a vraiment sa place c'est
à dire qu'au lieu de porter 30 kilos et
d'avoir le
pulvérisateur sur le dos et d'être dans
le nuage de produits le l'opérateur il
est totalement en dehors de ça Adrien
Berlioz vignerons savoyard depuis
maintenant 15 ans est un des clients de
Benoît pain g et alors que la
réglementation française interdit pour
le moment l'épandage aérien de produit
phytosanitaire il en a même profité pour
repenser son modèle du coup on a
réfléchi autrement et on s'est dit on va
utiliser que des produits naturels
pourquoi pas de l'homéopathie pourquoi
pas des huiles essentielles après tout
type de produit comme les purins les
décoctions etc et du coup on a on s'est
dit bah voilà on va limiter vraiment
tous les produits phytopharmaceutiques
en attendant de savoir si les drones ne
pulvérisation peuvent à terme devenir
une solution pérenne Benoît Pinge est un
des 6 membres fondateur de la patate une
association qui oeuvre à la
structuration et à l'évolution de la
législation
voilà et l'usage des drones je vous le
disais ce fait surtout aujourd'hui pour
la production audiovisuelle regardez à
ce propos c'est très belles images
fournies par nos partenaires de la
Dépêche du Midi du chemin de halage dans
le Lot un sentier comme vous le voyez au
cœur d'une falaise qui avait une
fonction commerciale par le passé il
fait aujourd'hui le bonheur des
promeneurs et de nos yeux avec ses
images très spectaculaires voilà c'est
la fin de cette édition du Grand JT des
territoires merci de nous avoir suivis
on se retrouve très vite pour une
prochaine édition au revoir à tous
[Musique]